[Music]
is with us in
albany new york hi wikis how are you hi
good thank you so much for taking my
call uh
i've actually just recently been
introduced to your program and i've been
watching your
youtube videos online um my question
was i've been thinking about getting a
new car for
about two years now and this is like my
dream car
and i wanted to like every time i try to
buy it and um
i hold off thinking that i should save a
bit more and then
and now i feel like i'm at a point where
i should take the
lead and buy this car and i just wanted
to make sure i'm
doing the right thing if not you know
you feel free to yell at me
[Laughter]
i'm not going to yell at you you sound
like a nice young man
i will instruct you firmly he yells at
me weakest
i am not a yeller okay so let's talk
let's talk
first thing is are you paying cash
yes okay that's the first rule of thumb
the second rule is
i'm a boy i love things with wheels and
motors that go vroom vroom
i don't care what it is a four-wheeler
on the farm the sea-doo in the
in the uh at the lake house or one of
the boats at the lake house the louder
the muffler the better because i'm a
good redneck
right and so uh
so i'm with you on car purchases the
thing i have learned
is that uh the car
boat sea doo rv
are the largest things that we buy
that go down in value and oh
boy do they go down in value it's
pretty much just like setting hundred
dollar bills on fire when you buy a
vehicle
right and so the the more
of that you do the less money you're
gonna have
and so the rule is that we use and i use
it personally as well
that i don't want things with motors or
wheels
or both that added all of them up
equal more than half my annual income
because i have too much going down in
value while i'm trying to go the other
way
okay so what do you make
uh from my day job no what do you make
what's your household income
in a year uh 85 grand
and then from my rental income i bring
in about
1500 a month so you own a rental house
yeah okay all right so that's another
eighteen thousand is that is that
and there's no payments on that that's
uh after i pay mortgage and uh taxes
okay all right so you got another 18 000
on top of your 85.
so let's call it 100 grand give or take
and
because you could probably got some
expenses on the rental but give or take
now the um car costs
what after taxes and fees about 50 grand
okay so you're right on that bubble of
50 percent
what's the car it's tesla model 3.
i was gonna guess okay all right
i have i mean i've saved up for it i
have about 100 grand in savings as well
okay that's right i don't have any other
any other
uh debt no credit card um i drive a 2007
toyota camry right now
i got you so so here's the thing
here's the thing yeah you can do this
because it fits our guidelines
it's a 50 of your income or less
and you're paying cash okay so if you
want to do it i'm not going to yell at
you you would go ahead and do it how old
are you
i'm 32. okay now but let me tell you
this
the more often that you repeat this
decision
the less money you're gonna have and you
have done unusually good with money you
have some money
so you're successful financially you're
doing good stuff with money
but just know that the more money we put
in a pile in the front yard and set fire
to it
the less money we're gonna have and
that's basically what you do when you
buy a car
so in other words don't do this again in
three years
don't do it don't do this again in eight
months okay you know that kind of a
thing right
so don't make a habit of being right on
the bubble
and having 50 because i got to tell you
i got a friend of mine that made 10
million dollars last year what if he put
50
of his income and stuff that went down
in value
that'd be like mathematical suicide and
so
that's in a sense right where you are if
you told me 60 i'd tell you not to buy
it
if you told me 70 i'd say don't buy it
no way
so you know you're smart you're wise
in that it is pinching your emotions a
little bit to do this
um you know what you might do i don't
know the model 3 because i don't know
the tesla's
but um what you might do is
back off and buy a two euro for 30.
that would probably be a better way to
scratch the itch
then if you wanted to move up later you
know
you could move up later in into a
another one oh
wait a minute if a model 3 is brand new
i wouldn't do that yeah i know because i
don't buy brand new cars that's the 30s
third
thing unless you have a million dollar
or greater net worth than you do not
and going from an 07 camry to a model 2
tesla is going to feel like you landed
on a rocket ship anyway
right you're i mean is it two the used
one is that what it is because he said
three
i'm just assuming so okay i don't know i
don't know what they are so
i mean if you if you ask me about a
pickup truck i'll probably tell you but
yeah
okay so anyway yeah you it br if it's
brand new that's the other thing i take
it off the table
that's the other part and not because
it's tesla just because there's anything
because the largest loss in value
is a brand new car right you're going to
lose because this thing's going to lose
60 to 70 percent of its value in the
first four years that's the average new
car and i have no idea what teslas do
but they are pretty much like anything
um
and you know yeah anyway
so it's uh um early in the days i tell
people not to buy tussles because you
might end up with a delorean
oh gotcha because we know if he's going
to go broke or not yeah apparently he's
musk is going to pull this out i mean
he's hanging on the fourth quarter he's
making it so i'm not going i'm going to
give him a hard time but
uh but uh yeah that that's so i don't
buy experimental stuff
right you know the first year of a brand
new car company is not what i don't i
don't need
i waited a few years to get a to get a
vcr right i wanted to
be i might want a delorean now that
would be cool man to have the back to
the future delorean that'd be
that'd be neat wouldn't it and they were
they're they're what they're like
stainless steel right
they weighed like nine million pounds
yeah but they could run on gigawatts
there's that yeah so yeah if it's brand
new we guess we're gonna take that off
the table
uh but that's the whole discussion but i
use tesla
it's a good it's a if that's what it was
it might have been you i didn't ask him
that before i let him go but
um it's a great discussion because
car payments listen if you're sitting
with two car payments and you keep two
car payments
you are making a statement and putting
it on the wall
in needlepoint i want to be middle class
my whole life
because car payments that says you're
buying new cars
and and you got payments all the time
and you're paying payments on things
that are going down in value
and you 100 mathematically are
destroying
your largest wealth building tool which
is your income
and so you're just you're just making
that statement you didn't mean to
but it's like needlepoint grandma used
to do oh yeah
framed right there i want to be middle
class my whole life that's why i have
two car payments
and so now if you want to be wealthy you
buy
you drive the camera drive the camera